why do those frazzle and dadgum
mainstream media muck spouts constantly
use such filthy concern language Senator
Marco Rubio calls out the potty mouths
on the left and we will analyze why the
left has made our culture so much
coarser then socialist Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez lies about where she's from and
grew up in order to score victim points
we will analyze because I'm from the
town right next to where she grew up
then Jennifer Rubin drops all pretense
of being a Republican finally we
celebrate the great unsung hero
President James Garfield one of one of
the great presidents on this day in
history most important of all Jeremy the
god king boring drops by from our sister
network daily wire to with an update on
the World Cup
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]
we got a lot going on today and I want
to ask why that F people are so effing
profane these days
but before all that in a special
livestream July 2nd at 7 p.m. Eastern we
will be joined by special guest Jordin
Petersen to celebrate Independence Day
not Canadian Independence Day American
Independence Day God king Jeremy boring
will host a new edition of daily wire
backstage with me Ben Shapiro and the
Andrew Klavan of the Andrew Clavin show
thee the one and only Lord of the
multiverse to look back on our country's
birth and look ahead to its future
subscribers will even be able to write
in live questions for us to answer on
the air and if you're not a subscriber
too bad become a subscriber again that's
today 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
with special guest Jordin be at Peterson
you can find our special live stream on
Facebook and YouTube so do not miss it
before we get to the god-king Jeremy
boring from our sister network daily
wire to let's make a little money honey
how about that huh keep the lights on
and talk about one of let me tell you I
don't want I don't want to give you guys
too much of a window into my boudoir you
know I'm a newly married man and
everything like to keep a little privacy
but Bolin brand sheets Oh are they good
I love Bolin brand sheets you know we're
never going to agree on everything but
we should we can certainly all agree
that we need more sleep getting a great
night's sleep is easier and more
affordable than you think you don't need
an expensive mattress or sleeping pills
you can just change out those sheets I
never knew this when I was a bachelor
because as many bachelors I slept on
like sandpaper from Target you know or
whatever the local store is you buy the
cheapest sheets whatever if you get
really nice sheets you sleep better you
feel like you're at a high-end hotel I'm
J it's it's really nice I put these on
my Bowlin Branch sent me a pair of these
sheets because obviously Ben hasn't paid
me in years but I get the freebies
sometimes I put them on I instantly
ordered another set and and actually
paid for them with the money Ben doesn't
pay me they're that good they are so so
good everything they make is made from
100% organic cotton they start out super
soft they get even softer over time
you're not going to pay a thousand
dollars for these sheets like a lot of
luxury sheets cost you buy directly from
them they cut out the middleman you're
only paying a couple hundred bucks
everyone who tries bond
she loves them they have thousands of
five-star reviews Forbes Wall Street
Journal Fast Company all talking about
them three u.s. presidents sleep on
Boland branch sheets James Garfield
because he was assassinated and he lived
in the 19th century did not have the
privilege of sleeping on bull and branch
sheets but I bet if he could he would
have shipping is free try them for 30
nights if you don't love them send them
back for a refund but you won't want to
send them back they're great get started
right now my listeners get $50 off your
first [ __ ] instead of first set of she
shells by the seashore
they get $50 of your first set of sheets
at Boland branch calm promo code Michael
mi CH AE L don't say I never did nothing
for you go to Boland branch comm today
$50 off your first set of sheets Bo ll
and branch comm promo code Michael mi CH
AE l if you occasionally entertain
boudoir guests or just sleep in there
yourself
treat yourself they're really really
good they make a great impression Boland
branch comm promo code Michael okay we
without further ado this is a big
weekend for the World Cup we turn now to
our sister network and daily wire to
sports correspondent Jeremy the god-king
boring scaramouche scaramouche will you
do the Fandango Michael enormous news
from the bear of the north as for the
second time in less than a century
Germany's dreams of global conquest
collapse in western Russia with their 2o
defeat at the hands of South Korea a
nation with roughly half of Germany's
GDP speaking to the BBC former German
champ Jurgen Klinsmann said quote it's
always difficult when you win to repeat
it four years later an admittedly
strange declaration from a nation that
has made failure look easy in every
generation since the franco-prussian war
of 1870 of course Germany who brought us
the fall of Rome the Dark Ages nihilism
Nazism two world wars trance music and
the failed project that is the EU is
never truly defeated and will
undoubtedly rise again from the ash heap
of history and prove that they can in
fact put a small ball roughly the size
of a human head through an enormous net
without the use of the hands that God
gave them as well as any third world
nation or France in other World Cup news
this week marks the close of the turn
group stage and the beginning of the
quarterfinals what this means is frankly
anybody's guess this sportscaster for
one stopped reading the Wikipedia entry
pretty early on if I'm being honest
because as a god-fearing American I just
couldn't be moved to give a flip about
what kind of archaic rules govern this
socialist non-sport I having far more
exciting things to do with my time like
dozing lightly in my armchair or
literally anything else I did ask
several people in my office who have
repeatedly assured me that I'm wrong to
criticize so beautiful a game if they
could give me a quick rundown of how it
all works before airtime but they all
reluctantly confessed to never having
actually watched a match before the
current World Cup started even though
they think it's hugely important
cultural event and I should be ashamed
of myself for blowing it off as nothing
more than a deliberate attempt to reduce
America from its status as shining city
on a hill down to parity with the lowest
common denominator equatorial hellhole
from which the soul of man used to cry
out for freedom and deliverance to so
great a nation as this but who now see
that we're not really all that great if
you really think about it because
without our hands and the complexity
with which we conquered war poverty
disease and death since the last world
war were really just like everybody else
also men are not stronger than women the
Millennium Falcon was never all that
fast and Batman could totally take
Superman in a fight even though the
ladder is invincible and can literally
shoot laser beams at the speed of light
from his eyes from space a place that
none of the country said if ever won the
World Cup have ever been to probably
probably because they haven't figured
out how to use their hands to be clear
to be clear however it's not the
position of this self entertained
journalist that the admittedly handsome
men who run around and fake injuries on
the soccer field are not athletes on the
contrary they are clearly quite fit and
able to run around if aimlessly for long
periods of time with no brakes the issue
is not that they aren't athletes it's at
soccer is not a sport it's an admittedly
mesmerizing bit of choreography in which
colorful objects move back and forth
across your screen and then nothing
happens here's a clip of one of the
weekends more interesting matches by way
of example
mesmerizing that's it for this week's
World Cup recap Michael scaramouch
scaramouch will you do the Fandango
back to you Jeremy that was such an
informative recap of the World Cup I
really appreciate that you know we were
talking a little bit there about a
Germany and strategy I was under I
talked about that I was under the
impression that a Germany strategy was
to have their competition in the World
Cup last a thousand years but it seems
to have been cut short we fear the the
the German soccer team rising up again
within say I don't know four to seven
years well Michael historically they
always have fortunately for us the brave
men and women of Western Europe who
formerly gave the world the British
Empire and complex manly sports such as
cricket and wealthy sports such as polo
will undoubtedly seek a peace for our
time and appease Germany all the way to
future catastrophe the one does wonder
if we should just dismantle the German
soccer team once and for all but it
seems to me that the international
community just no no they have the right
to pride as a nation and we shouldn't
stand in their way all they're looking
for is a little breathing room mm-hmm
that's absolutely right you know Jeremy
we've heard a lot of from the left about
how awful Russia is these days and and
the United States colluded with Russia
but they're hosting this most wonderful
and important international sporting
event should we just give them a free
pass well obviously this sportscaster
doesn't know much about politics but I
will say that of all the things that
Donald Trump has done that have offended
those in the former never Trump
contingent perhaps winning the World Cup
for the United States America eight
years hence is the worst and the
greatest proof that he seeks to follow
in the footsteps of mass murderer
flatten Ameer Putin in reducing the
world down to a sort of pre
civilizational hell from which even
Jordan B Peterson's philosophy may not
be able to save us I'll have to reread
Alexander Solzhenitsyn it's been a while
going into Gulag Archipelago jeremy the
god-king boring from daily wire to a
very important update and basically has
convinced me now to go nevertrump Jeremy
thanks for being here we'll talk to you
soon
stare at mooch you know I think and on
this episode I want to talk about just
how profane our culture has gotten and
specifically the left why the left is
just become so profane they just have
terrible potty mouths and there is no
more profane way to begin and talking
about soccer so I'm glad we could get
that out of the way really really
informative on on the question of
profanity you might have seen Marco
Rubio tweet out over the weekend about
how bad the the culture has gotten how
coarse the culture has gotten and I'm
not saying it's because people say
naughty words people have always said
naughty words it's because they're doing
it so publicly now and that the left has
really embraced this Marco Rubio he
tweeted out quote sign of our times the
f-word is now used routinely in news
stories tweets etc it's not even F star
star star anymore who made that decision
and it's funny like as he says this I
was thinking about that I said you're
right it used to be F star star star
asterisk asterisk asterisk try to say
that three times fast but now they don't
even do that they just say it and as I'm
doing that Kathy Griffin the former
comedian the alleged comedian Kathy
Griffin starts tweeting at me and
calling me a mother effer and I actually
I this people didn't understand this but
I tweeted that out I said Oh everybody
Kathy Griffin just called me a mother
effer
but without the asterisks and people
thought I was like whining about that I
was referencing Marco Rubio because she
proved the left always does this the
right makes an observation and they say
no we're not like that and they
immediately prove the Wrights point so I
got into this this little Twitter fight
for a while with Kathy Griffin because I
pointed out all she does now is scream
profanity on Twitter and on television
at former Republican officials so she
did she sent out this tweet she said if
you Ari Fleischer or E Fleischer was the
first press secretary for President Bush
I said that you know that isn't comedy
you can probably get an audience too
you can probably endear yourself to
angry Democrats but it isn't comedy it's
kind of just cheap it's like a cheat in
entertainment so she responds she goes I
just did two big shows at Radio City
Music Hall in Carnegie Hall along with
shows in San Francisco Seattle Portland
and Boston so someone disagrees with you
mother-effer and I said what you're
actually kind of showing my point I'm
not saying you can't sell shows Jimmy
Kimmel has now made a career on claps
not laughs to use Owen Benjamin's phrase
he's you know they're going out there
and instead of actually working up jokes
and trying to be funny they're just
going out and saying mean things about
Republicans and that's supposed to
substitute for a joke and this has been
going on for a long time it's just a
cheapness and what it shows is that the
culture has gotten a little stupid or in
a little coarser and a little shallower
but we'll explain why because this isn't
just about Kathy Griffin this isn't just
about Donald Trump this isn't about this
has been going on for a long time and
it's been brought up by the left so
obviously it's all over TV it's all over
music I'm sure even for you know our
audience I think is 99.7% millennial and
then the rest is whatever comes after
millennial but even growing up when
Millennials grew up that you didn't hear
these things really on TV but but now
they're all over TV the much more
profane words than were when we were
kids or all over music every other word
is the f-word right I was riding the
subway in New York this was a couple
months ago I'm sitting there and some
guy was he had his boombox or speakers
or whatever and he's blasting out this
very profane gangster rap where every
other word is the f-word of the n-word
and that's all it is he's sitting next
to these like nice little old women and
I would have intervened except he was
big and scary and wearing sort of the
gang colored paraphernalia and listen
man I don't need to be a hero okay I
don't need to die on the 4:00 train but
everyone was just looking at him and he
was staring at everybody else like I
sort of challenged you know I this is
the culture now this is what we're gonna
put out here and when did this store why
did this begin a lot of people blame
South Park but I really want to defend
South Park here Trey Parker and Matt
Stone show you know since the late 90s
and the kids had potty mouths but South
Park sort of curse
ironically like these kids were showing
something about the culture right but
they would even joke about swear words
they did an episode where they said if
everybody just starts swearing in public
all the time then the swear words don't
have any meaning they don't they don't
do anything like you the in order for
the for profanity to be profane you have
to have the sacred because it has to
counter the sacred it has to undercut
the sacred so I actually think South
Park have been the great observers of
this trend I don't think that caused it
it's been happening for a long time why
did it happen part of this is freedom so
part of this is that you know in the old
days when everything was just network
television then you could have people
come out standards bureaus and say you
can't use this word on TV you can't use
this word on TV George Carlin had the
seven words you can't say on TV special
right all these naughty words but then
once you have all of the streaming
platforms once it's all really just part
of the internet or new media you can't
do that anymore
right there's knows that you can't go to
every blog and to every web series and
say no you said a naughty word same
thing with music music used to censor
their their naughtiest words you know
and a lot of that was Walmart so you
know Walmart was a major seller of CDs
they would say we're not gonna sell
explicit CDs and so the producers in the
studios would say okay I guess we have
to put out a cleaner cleaner version too
if we want to actually sell them now
that we have streaming now that music is
just free and everyone just puts it
right into their cars or right into
their homes that doesn't exist anymore
and so there is this impulse for human
freedom and in a libertine culture to
just constantly do whatever people say
that you can't do we'll explain how this
has infected politics and why it
probably doesn't spell a good good end
for the Democrat Party and will also
make fun of Alexandria Ocasio Cortes for
lying about her where she's from and it
is a lie people are trying to say it
isn't a lie now it is before we do that
got to make a little more money honey
how are at these these lights they don't
keep themselves on and we this is this
is a really important one because
obviously you know when
and Shapiro was putting together some of
these shows he didn't use it recruiter
hence my lovely set up here I get my
show you know it's really nice if he had
used the soup recruiter he'd be much
happier these days I mean you'd be I
don't know what show this would be now
this would be the Ben Shapiro to show
you know but zip recruiter is a
wonderful sponsor and they will really
really make hiring very very easy zipper
cruder it sends your job over to one
hundred of the web's leading job boards
but they don't just stop there so in the
old days you'd put your job on a job
board and then it would just die would
somehow get dust on the internet you
know because yours posted who get the
Internet is just people screaming into
the ether right what zip recruiter does
is it actually finds you the candidates
so with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes finds people with the right
experience and invites those people to
apply for your job makes it much faster
time is money it's much more efficient
it finds qualified people who are a
match zip recruit are so effective that
eighty percent of employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day so
you it has spotlights those top
candidates you won't miss a good
candidate
everybody knows this the team is
important I like it really I will say
that even though I've been you know
wants to like clobber me every single
day in the studio having a team is
really what makes businesses work the
the people that you have so with results
like that it's no wonder that zip
recruiter is the highest rated hiring
site in America right now my listeners
can try zip recruiter for free don't say
I never did nothing for you at this
exclusive web address zip recruiter comm
slash MKS go there right now oh wait
I'll wait all day
zip recruiter dot-com / MKS zip
recruiter zi PR EC or UI ter dot-com do
T Co m / SLA SH MKS zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire ok so you remember
this even in in movies this is the case
all the great movies ever made were made
in 1939 somehow you know phenomenal
films going with the wind weathering
heights I believe what's the most famous
movie ever made
The Wizard of Oz the Wizard of Oz made
in 1939 when there was sort of not
censorship but there were standards
boards that you had to watch out for and
then when those went away the quality
declined but this isn't just the case in
pop culture so part of the reason is
like you know sonnets like poetry is
good when there are constraints on it
because then the creativity comes out
and you're you're working within
constraints but slam poetry is the death
of art it's the worst thing ever
invented this is one of the great
plagues to ever reflect mankind why
because there are no constraints oh it's
just nothing we're seeing this in
politics we're seeing the slam poetry of
politics brought to you courtesy of the
Democrat Party here is not a random
activist not a random resistance fighter
not any of that this is the head of the
Democrat Party Tom Perez here's just a
little clip of his soaring rhetoric
those Republican leaders and President
Trump don't give it about the people
they were trying to hurt you've got
bright he's a liar my friends budget is
another example of broken promises the
budget is bankrupt they call it a skinny
budget I call it a budget I don't want
people to think I'm being a prude here
or something or I'm being too formal or
something
obviously when guys hang out they
frequently use salty language they
frequently talk like Tom Perez I don't
begrudge any guy that there there is a
kind of social impulse for that the
difference here is is the public nature
of all of this because it isn't just the
head of the DNC its senators it's the
activists it's the rank-and-file
its pundits on television its cultural
figures and commentators they're all
using filthy language in public and what
it shows is a decay and the ability of
these people to think decay and how they
think a decay in their respect for
themselves for their country for their
party for what they're doing and for
other people around them you know
there's a reason that you don't swear in
front of little old ladies you can talk
in a bar with your pals and you know
speak in a certain way and you
don't speak that way with little old
ladies it's about respect I'll just
compare have you ever listened to pod
save America
I had never listened to it pod save
America are those guys from the Obama
administration and so they created their
own podcast it's like the left-wing
Daily wire I sort of write I mean it's
this kind of these political guys he
started these big podcasts I had never
listened to it
pod save America is so bad but it's so
beautifully bad like there are so many
things bad about it it made me feel much
better sometimes you wonder you say oh I
wonder how our the guys on the Left are
doing this or wieszczyk or whatever oh
my goodness gracious every single day
Lee Weyer show is like a Shakespearean
tragedy compared to the drivel glib
nonsense put out by bad save America
here is just a little clip to underscore
a few points that we're talking about
here from whatever random episode I
listen to of POD save America we're not
there are things we can do and so I
think about this is like what can do in
the short-term the medium-term in a long
term to deal with this massive problem
so short-term is blow up the phone lines
at the Senate we've said this before now
it's really true literally the most
important election of our lifetime ever
more than a presidential election at
this point this is like the last call
for democracy because here's how the
Supreme Court thing shakes so that you
you know he is serious right you know
he's serious because he said the f-word
he said he's we're animals just even I
hate to I don't want to like get into
just personal insults or psychobabble or
whatever but he the guy sounds like a
Democrat doesn't he hears the voice of
just like well I I can't even do it I
don't even know how I don't know how
many years of conservatory training I
have I can't do that voice of a Democrat
that's sort of like Marlon Brando when
he did the Godfather he put cotton balls
in his mouth to listen Tom this is a
Muslim right and they would have create
that sound
all right you would have to put a little
like soy balls in your mouth too
you'd have to have the soy in there
that's the best to me and I'm not going
to go down that road but he said they
kept really serious lefties do this a
lot so I'm really serious I'm gonna say
the f-word that's how you know I'm
serious I'm if I just spoken like an
adult then
you wouldn't know you know and it's just
this whining but all they do listen on
pod save America and all it is is like
talking point innuendo
so all they they say the Supreme Court
seat was stolen how is it stolen they
can't they don't know they didn't and
Trump is colluding with Putin they hat
can you explain that at all no of course
not you're just going over right it's
all this but but it's that the reliance
on the F word is though that makes you
smarter or whittier or funnier or more
insightful but it doesn't it's a
substitute for that it's when you don't
have insight or wit or or whatever that
you can that you have to rely on those
sorts of words and it is really sad you
know some people now whenever I point
this out
they send around these these surveys
that show allegedly that people who
swear are smarter they have a higher IQ
and there might be something to this but
really the way these studies are done is
that they're just about people's a
facility with language so they'll see
how people can swear or what you know
what sort of ways they use language and
it's true if you if you can swear or if
you can use regular language on non
profane language if you can use it very
well that's a sign of high IQ that's why
you know I think nobody has ever matched
the concision which is brevity being the
soul of wit of my number one
best-selling book reasons to vote for
Democrats a comprehensive guide I mean
that's really the most concise and fluid
use of language in modern literature and
so I thank everybody you know for
reading that and clearly they're all
scholars and scientists to the but the
ability to use profanity and to move
these words around might be evidence of
a high IQ but use it but if it's the
question is when is it appropriate to
use it because the people that I hear
using profanity in public or next to
little old ladies on the train they
don't seem to have a very high IQ I
don't think that they you know I don't
think they go home at night and read
Aristotle or something I think they're
you know they're they're public louts
basically I mean they're just vulgar
people who don't show a lot of respect
so sure you can have a great command of
language and I know plenty of people who
speak very properly and and politely in
public who
can talk like a sailor some time with
the boys that's all fine what it what it
means when you use language like pod
save America does or the head of the DNC
or these other left-wing pundits it
means that you don't have any self
control you don't have any discipline
you you can't control yourself you don't
it actually shows the opposite of what
those parent IQ studies are supposed to
show you you aren't able to control your
language you all you what it also shows
is this lack of respect for the audience
that people around you people who might
not want to hear that you know someone
says well who cares it's all over the
place
do I really clutch my pearls when I hear
the F word and no I mean you hear it a
lot but it's sort of like a person with
perfect pitch this is it with like
civilized people
polite people and civilized people who
don't say a lot of naughty words when
they hear a lot of profane language it
does bother them in the way that it
might not bother other people who deal
in that all the time just like when
someone who has perfect pitch here's a
note that's just a little bit off it
really bothers them because they know
where the pitch is supposed to be
whereas someone who has bad pitch you
know who can't really hear the
difference in pitch and tone it won't
bother them at all because they're just
less cultured they're less attuned to
that same thing with profanity and just
compare some of this rhetoric that we're
hearing you hear it on pod save America
you heard from the head of the Democrat
Party
compare that to oh I don't know the
Gettysburg Address you know one of the
great pieces of rhetoric in American
history I'll just read it's a short
speech that's pretty quick
just compare what that what this
language does to you compared to what
Tom Perez does to you the Gettysburg
Address reads four score and seven years
ago our fathers brought forth on this
continent a new nation conceived in
Liberty and dedicated to the proposition
that all men are created equal now we
are engaged in a great Civil War testing
whether that nation or any nation so
conceived and so dedicated can long
endure we are met on a great battlefield
of that war
we have come to dedicate a portion of
that field as a final resting place for
those who here gave their lives that
that nation might live it is altogether
fitting and proper that we should do
this but in a larger sense we cannot
dedicate we cannot consecrate we cannot
hallow this ground
the brave men living and dead who
struggled here have consecrated it far
above
poor power to add or detract the world
will little note nor long remember what
we say here but it can never forget what
they did here it is for us the living
rather to be dedicated here to the
unfinished work which they who fought
here have thus far so nobly advanced it
is rather for us to be here dedicated to
the great task remaining before us that
from these honored dead we take
increased devotion to that cause for
which they gave the last full measure of
devotion that we here highly resolve
that these dead shall not have died in
vain that this nation under God shall
have a new birth of freedom and the
government of the people by the people
for the people shall not perish from the
earth what if he had sprinkled in just a
couple f-bombs you know wouldn't that
have really shown he cared he was really
passionate kirsten gillibrand people
blame this on Trump they say well Trump
uses naughty language in public and
sometimes he does much less so since
he's been in office because he's getting
better about this but sure this long
predates Donald Trump this is not
exclusive to him it and it's really been
brought up by the left Kirsten
Gillibrand was talking to New York
magazine a few years ago she said if
we're not helping people we should go
the eff home when she started in the
Senate she said she had no effing clue
how to pass a bill why say that and I
don't look sometimes people use swear
words in private sometimes they
accidentally say them in public and they
say oh pardon my french sorry I didn't I
shouldn't have said that people do they
make that mistake but she's trying to
say she's taking pride in saying in 2004
long before Donald Trump was a
presidential candidate Kerry John Kerry
running for president said that george w
bush effed the country up effed up the
country he said he just publicly why
would you try to say that publicly
there's clearly something going on here
with the way that people are approaching
respect and in the way that they're
talking about their their fellow
countrymen if this is the same reason by
the way to use titles some people think
it's crazy to say mr. Smith mr. and mrs.
John Smith or something this is a big
issue when I was doing wedding
invitations you have everyone now wants
weird wacky
else you know you have to say mr. and
mrs. John Smith or mrs. Jane sue and mr.
John Smith or whatever all these things
they said why are you using mr. and mrs.
and doctorates so old school you just
now we get rid of these I learned this
from a seminar with leon kass the great
bioethicists we're in the seminar we're
all 1820 year old kids we would say okay
instead of saying hey John you had this
idea about the book and I think it's
this use mr. Smith mr. Jones mister
whatever and it does elevate the
conversation that formality elevates
things it's why in Congress and in
Parliament and even in little debating
societies if you'll use Robert's Rules
of Order it's why there is etiquette you
know the word etiquette the French word
etiquette appears in its modern use in
around 1750 and coincidentally that's
the height of our civilization right
there the peak of modernity and it all
really declines from there etiquette is
are these formal rules these manners
this civility that we all agree to do
not because we love them not because
we're pearl clutching not because we're
prude but because it makes the world
more pleasant makes things a nicer and
it facilitates communication and it's a
little nice you know today there's no
respect for the culture profanity is the
profane right it is it shows irreverence
for the sacred there's the profane and
there's the sacred so to show that
irreverence for that for this culture is
because you don't like it because you
hate it because you know if you have
manners it means you were raised right
means you have respect you were taught
respect from a young age the people who
little kids who say every little kid
says curse words and usually their
parents say stop saying them right and
don't say that isn't polite to do people
don't like that you don't see that as
much anymore and that that isn't just a
you know that look there are a lot of
problems with the family but it's it's
this deeper cultural problem people
don't have any respect for their country
they people need to stop this the reason
not to use swear words in public I
suppose you can use them in private and
then you sound like a cool guy is
because they they just course in
everything around
and they lose their power so when you a
really well-placed f-bomb in a private
conversation at a bar is a beautiful
thing and it really you know can really
liven up a story but when it becomes the
mode of the culture it's just blah it's
just gross and unpleasant no one wants
to live like that
the reason not to use swear words is
because you have respect for yourself
you know that the left tends to hate
Western civilization because they hate
their country because they hate
themselves they there is a self-hatred
that comes out of that left-wing self
flagellation don't do it you know when
you're in public just have respect for
people around you you show respect for
yourself someone who doesn't have any
respect for herself is Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez the socialista who won in Queens
she's posing herself as this a city girl
let's see do I have to sign off I get to
this story then I'll have to sign off
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez just unseated
Joe Crowley big up said she's running as
an open socialist and she says president
Trump has never had to deal with a girl
from the Bronx like me said a girl from
the Bronx huh let me do like three
seconds of a google search and oh and
that's a lie she's not Alexandria Cortez
I was born in the Bronx and then before
elementary school she moved up to the
suburbs to Yorktown Heights which is in
Westchester County and she grew up in a
very privileged position and now people
are saying she's been trying to by the
way pose herself as this you know she
never really moved up she just went to
school there whatever it's a lie and
even people on the right right now are
are trying to defend her from this I
have a unique perspective in that I also
lived as a baby in a poor part of New
York City and then I also before
Elementary School moved up to
Westchester County coincidentally to the
town right next to the town that she is
from and actually the only difference
here is that she was born in Parkchester
in the Bronx and I lived my first baby
moments in Sheepshead Bay Brooklyn which
is slightly less affluent and less and
more racially diverse and then she moved
up to Yorktown Heights in Westchester I
moved up to Bedford Hills which is much
more racially diverse and much less
affluent than the town she grew up in so
these are almost parallel
stories and I can tell you man we grew
up a pretty posh childhood it is hard to
beat that in terms of safety in terms of
school districts in terms of relative
affluence even if our families I can't
speak for her family but even if we
didn't have a ton of money you know
you're just in such an affluent area
that is a privileged upbringing people
go to great universities from there
because it's a good place to be with
good education she is trying to spin it
I've I've never denied how great it was
I'm very grateful to have had a
relatively pleasant childhood she's
denying it and years has she's denying
it people are saying she's just using
language creatively it's a it's a
flat-out lie she writes on her campaign
website from an early age Alexandria
grew up with a deep understanding of
income inequality the state of Bronx
public schools in the late 1980s and
early 1990s sent her parents on search
for a solution she ended up attending
public school 40 minutes north in
Yorktown and much of her life was
defined by the 40-minute commute between
school and her family in the Bronx it
was clear to her even then that the zip
code a child was born in to determine
much of their destiny the 40-minute
drive represented a vastly different
quality of schooling Economic
Opportunity and health outcomes that's
true she didn't commute
she didn't commute she did what she is
saying what makes it a lie is the
commute part a commute is a regular
journey that she lived in the Bronx and
she went to school in New York town
which is not possible by the way to
access these public schools you have to
live in the town where the school is so
that's obviously a lie she lives in
Yorktown Heights she didn't live in the
Bronx if she means that she went to
visit relatives in the Bronx okay you
and every other person in Westchester
County I went to visit relatives in the
Bronx or as a kid everybody did that's
not a commute that's going on a trip to
Grandma's house you don't commute to
Grandma's house I didn't go on I
commuted to Florida to see my
grandparents that's not a commute that's
a lot as she's lying and John put her
its whom I like but he's wrong about
this he tweeted out at some conservative
commentator who observed this lie he
said good god you're a know-nothing
schmuck Yorktown Heights is an ethnic
suburb the most modest in the county now
go be a pig somewhere else I disagree
with Cortez on everything but you're a
repellent slime bucket of a person I
don't know where all that anger came
from
what he said about Yorktown Heights just
flat-out is not true it is not only is
it not the most modest town in
Westchester County it's one of the more
affluent ones it's the the median
household income is I believe more than
double what the median household income
was in my home town in Westchester right
next door and my hometown was pretty
nice a York town if he's talking about
an ethnic neighborhood the ethnicity
would have to be white that's the that's
the ethnicity of that neighborhood
Yorktown Heights is 88% white I believe
in those days it was even higher 88%
white of some Asian then I think five to
six percent Asian and a little bit
Hispanic my hometown one town over
Bedford Hills fifty-three percent white
40 some-odd percent Hispanic and two or
three percent black 1 1 2 3 percent
black much more ethnically diverse much
less affluent but they're all they're
all defending her on this don't don't
defend her on this it's a flat-out lie
and this is gonna talk her by the way
I won't matter in the CD I mean the seat
is basically a lock it's not that a
Republican is suddenly gonna flip this
district that nominated a socialist but
it's gonna dog her in the way that
Pocahontas has dogged Elizabeth Warren
because especially at this time in
politics authenticity matters
we talked about that in the elvis donald
trump segment last thursday authenticity
matters here and what we now know about
her is she's a liar about her identity
she tweeted at some conservative talking
about that she said you're trying to rob
me of me out my identity the only person
robbing you of your identity is you
because you're utterly lying about it
but Pocahontas Elizabeth Warren is not a
Native American and you were not raised
in the Bronx you were raised in a very
affluent suburb you should be grateful
for that and you should try to spread
abundance and prosperity to your fellow
countrymen instead of lying and playing
the victim and pretending that you're
you're something that you're not in
trying to spread poverty and misery
division and victimhood to your
constituents to win an election it's a
cynical misrepresentation it's very
disrespectful to people who didn't have
the privileges that she had and she
should be ashamed she'll probably win
this seat but it's going to dog her she
is she this is her Pocahontas moment
okay I got us a good pie I'm running
really late to Facebook and YouTube by
the time we get back I've got to talk
about the greatest president one of the
great presidents in American history I
also have to make
of Jennifer Rubin if you want to see all
that you got to go to daily wire.com
yeah it's ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me at the end
reclaim ensure you get the Ben Shapiro
show you get to ask questions in the
mailbag you get to ask questions in the
conversation that we're just about to
have with me one and only Jordan B
Peterson none of that none of that
matters this we're doing local batches
now of leftist ears we're doing a little
it's kind of microbrews and this is this
is a lovely little batch from Yorktown
Heights they're known for their their a
beautiful blend of salt and water a
really good leftist I understand a
little well mmm
that's good if I were on the Left I
would say that's effing good so that you
know that I'm serious go to daily
wired.com we'll be right back to make
fun of Jennifer Rubin and talk about
President Garfield
I really quickly in our last moments
here some good moves over the weekend
for the culture for the politics
Jennifer Rubin the favorite fake
Republican of the mainstream media more
than Anna Navarro more than Steve
Schmidt Jennifer Rubin who has pretended
to be a conservative for many many years
now is calling for life long mob
harassment of Sarah Huckabee Sanders
because she had the audacity the villany
to be a press secretary in a Republican
administration here is fake Republican
Jennifer Rubin but we're not going to
let these people go through life
unscathed
Sarah Huckabee has no right to live a
life of no fuss no muss after lying to
the press after inciting against the
press these people should be made
uncomfortable and I think that's a life
sentence frankly a life sentence you
heard a Jennifer Rubin said it you heard
it from her folks this is a I'm glad
she's finally really showing her colors
here because the the left does this we
don't really get a lot of fake Democrats
unfortunately other than Joe Manchin I
hope you have one in the Senate but you
know we don't originally the Republicans
haven't gathered our own fake Democrats
but they gather their own fake
Republicans Steve Schmidt Anna Navarro
Jennifer Rubin and more kind of come in
and out I'll be nice and not call out
some of the people who I think are being
used for Democrat purposes but Jennifer
Rubin is really one of the worst and she
listen to what she's calling for here
Sarah Sanders is one of the most
competent people in the administration
and maybe in the country I mean she's
really really good at her job
she's a clear communicator she doesn't
lie she they try to accuse her of all
sorts of wickedness and evil she seems
like a total straight shooter
she's all-around a good woman she always
had a reputation until she had the great
audacity to work for the Republican
president she's calling for her to be
harassed for the rest of her life there
is no difference between Jennifer Rubin
and Maxine Waters right now there's no
difference between the craziest insane
left-wing democrat congresswoman and the
person that Washington Post pretends is
their conservative columnist it's a
total force and this is one
the tricks of the mainstream media is
they they put out their own
conservatives who aren't really
conservative so they say we're balanced
we're presenting both sides of the
opinion the New York Times does this
they have David Brooks he's the concern
he's not a conservative endorsed Barack
Obama because of the crease of his pants
that's not a conservative Washington
Post has Jennifer Rubin but there isn't
actually intellectual diversity here
there is just the pretense of
intellectual diversity there's the
pretense of political diversity it seems
to have worked well for these mainstream
outlets for a long time I wonder if the
right shouldn't try to emulate that
because even Fox News there have been a
few kind of squishy Democrats who have
gone on there but not really at least
Fox is generally pretty honest about
this and when they bring a lefty on they
let that lefty go crazy and humiliate
himself but when the the left-wing
outlets bring a conservative on it's
always conservatives who aren't really
conservatives who just say Democrat
talking points and that really shows you
something it shows that the right is not
afraid to hear different points of view
why because we're confident in our
message and in our argument and if
someone presents a different argument
that's better
I guess we'll change our mind but that's
probably unlikely because we are right
most of the time the left is terrified
of hearing the conservative argument
they don't let it come on their shows
they don't air it I've never once been
invited on a left-wing Network a lot of
my friends who also you know sometimes
go on Fox News or other media outlets do
not get invites on CNN or on pod save
America that horrific podcast they would
never do it I would have pod save
America guys come on this show any time
I'd love to talk to them I've begged
Democrats to come on this show Tom
Arnold is the only one with the guts to
do it basically which is why I like Tom
Arnold he gave one of the wilder
interviews maybe in the history of
broadcasting but at least the guy had
the guts to come on the the left will
not have Republicans on it's because
they're afraid it tells you everything
you need to know so good I hope Jennifer
Rubin gets two columns now I hope she
gets to call for mob terror against
Republicans in two separate columns it
shows them for what they are phonies who
can't stand up to the light of scrutiny
okay before we go I've got a were
already running late I've got to get to
this day in history with
one of the great unsung American
presidents James Garfield James Garfield
on this day in history was shot he
didn't die he didn't die until until
September I believe and this was this
day in history in 1881 James Garfield
only really served as president for four
months because then he was shot and
really kind of out of it though I guess
technically he served for six months
the James Garfield was a forgettable
president in if you talked to history
teachers and you look at mainstream
history curricula he was a good
president he was a very promising
president he had a good start he was
devoted to Liberty he was a Republican
not only from the beginning of his
career he was a Republican from the
beginning of the party the Republican
Party was founded in 1856 to free the
Democrats slaves and by 1857 when he
entered into politics he was 22 years
old he became a Republican for that
reason it was deeply committed to civil
rights for all Americans including black
Americans he was cleaned up government
he was an anti-corruption candidate and
he was nominated by accident in this
really great American way at the 1880
GOP presidential nomination contest at
the GOP convention he was the campaign
manager for then Secretary of the
Treasury John Sherman and he gave the
nominating speech for this guy John
Sherman for president and Sherman
ulysses s grant and James Blane were
vying for it and they couldn't get
enough votes none of them could meet the
threshold to become the nominee of the
party so as a compromise candidate on
these 36th ballot James Garfield was
able to get the nomination and his vice
president was Chester Arthur the 36th
ballot you know now the nominating
conventions are all sort of a farce they
were decided beforehand or whatever this
was the real deal this is actually where
they picked their nominee it wasn't just
the appearance of the thing it actually
did what it said it was doing which is
figuring out how to nominate a candidate
and so James Garfield gets it on the
seventy or on the 36th ballot the reason
I really have a soft spot in my heart
for him I'll have to lean back to one of
my my great literary works
James Garfield invented the blank book
as an American literary genre you know I
have a certain affinity for blank
political books the first blank book in
American political history is a book
called I'm gonna get the title a little
bit off but the statesmanship and
political achievements of General
Winfield Scott Hancock the regular
Democrat nominee for president so you
know that it would be like Trump saying
here here's my book the accomplishments
of Hillary Clinton and it's all blank it
was a five page blank book in 1880 and
obviously now you know paper is a lot
cheaper printing it's a little bit
easier so I was able to have two hundred
some odd pages they could only do five
back then but it was so great because
the first blank book in American
political history was a Republican
trolling a Democrat and not just any
Republican the nominee for president
dropping a Democrat really really good
he was killed with him you know it was
shot within four months killed within
six and nevertheless in that very short
amount of time now these days it takes
two years to get anything done if you're
president other than if you're Donald
Trump but this guy was able to pull back
presidential appointment power from the
Senate in those four months rebuild
America's Navy make it great again and a
purge corruption from some federal
agencies from the post office he was
able to purge cannot an easy thing to do
he was very big on education was very
big on civil rights good president would
have been a really good president if had
he lived longer
he gave us Chester Arthur afterward
another great president but a guy who is
forgotten on his deathbed or near his
deathbed he said will will I have made
any mark on history will history
remember me and and he did he turned the
country a little bit in the right
direction and he was a he was a good man
and he gave us Chester Arthur will go
into him some other day but he was an
important president too and a salute to
President Garfield because he changed
history in a very important way he made
me a lot of money and that's a very
important thing and he and he gave us
one of one of my favorite roles you know
of the year 2017 and a mark of the
exuberance of the right
after the election of Donald Trump so
you made your mark President Garfield
and you're by your book was all
inspiration for mine okay that's the
show we have some amazing guests coming
up this week I don't want to say when I
did interview geese jung-ho the North
Korean defector who famously at the
State of the Union he raised his
crutches and he was totally maimed and
disfigured in Korea trekked thousands
and thousands of miles as that tyranny
you know tortured his family to death i
sat down with him he's the most heroic
person probably I'll ever meet we'll
have that interview coming for you in a
few days so be sure to tune in in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles is the
Michael Nolt show and I'll see you on
Daily wire backstage in like I don't
know five minutes
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you